one of the things that struck me most
about both the book in the movie is just
how many passions and hobbies are on
display here in character sharing that
with another character so for you guys
personally do you have any particular
passion or hobby that if someone else
learned about it and they're not exposed
to it already you think that it can make
a difference in their life that's a
great question I don't know if you agree
with this but I think writing is a huge
one I think for a lot of people some
people think that writing has to be done
in a specific way or format or you have
to have a specific type of you've had to
have a specific type of study or
knowledge behind the subject but I think
writing is one of those things that it
is there's no boundaries or limits and
it can help people in a lot of different
ways whether you're dealing with anxiety
or whether you're just dealing with you
know wanting to expand your creative
brain cells or use it as a way to
inspire you to you know whether it's
writing scripts or songs or plays or
whatever it may be
I think writing is a good one yeah
absolutely I agree I feel like you know
things like that in my hobbies like like
writing or or even dancing you know it's
it's very therapeutic for a lot of
people you know they can kind of use it
to as a kind of escape you know hey
you're done are you done do you like to
dance a little bit writing and that's
why I was like vetting and dancing I was
like yeah both go hand in hand
what about vision boards vision boards
all right yeah all believe in you and
see how it comes to this I'm all about
pets anytime I can go out there and tell
somebody to get a pet and bring a pet
into your life I feel like that's a
great way to share some sort of joy if
somebody else hasn't already done that
another thing that really stands out
about the movie is a cast chemistry
which is just through the roof
constantly so can you tell me a little
bit about working with George and maybe
what he did with you guys to prep what
notes he gave to really bring that
through so powerfully I've never been
worked with the director as passionate
and you know that the time he puts into
the chemistry of these characters me and
a man left for two weeks before we
started shooting were just like hanging
out with George talking about like our
motives and scenes and stuff and that
was that was a game changer for me it
changes the whole game when you do that
because it's just the work becomes so
much more fluid I think yeah and even
with the Carter Family you know you got
us all together we'd go go-karting
together we go for dinners we you know I
just do a whole bunch of bonding things
for us to kind of just make that dynamic
in the chemistry just super organic it's
so important that yeah and I just yeah
I'm really happy that translates
on-screen oh absolutely
the family it's I mean you really do
feel like you you've lived with them and
it's kind of hard to leave them in the
end - George it's also very
collaborative questions if I didn't
agree or anything like that I just bring
in try this man you know yeah that's
great yeah I used very much like an
actor's director you know he's really
for the actor and for the craft and you
know he allows you to also make your own
decisions you know and then he kind of
he's very big on like collaboration and
in compromise and he looks like that and
he'll admit like he'll admit if if
something he said didn't work you know
and like you you were right you know
which is which is cool and I wasn't even
there during the actual shoot the main
shooting of the movie but you could tell
that George is literally he's dreaming
about the movie - he goes home or just
thinking about is oh yeah is the yeah
just always in his step like even is why
he's like you know when you guess like
[Applause]
it's interview before talking monitor so
into it doesn't amaze me it gets us so
involved too to see a director that's so
passionate about everything it makes us
want to give him all we have overtly
passion he doesn't keep his passion to
stop no lets it out
[Music]